paris les halles monsieur chirac après
une réunion de travail mais ce galet et
jaro pour étudier des problèmes de la
qualité de la vie a fait une visite
impromptue sur le chantier des halles
il n'a fait aucune déclaration à ce
sujet mais on pense que des décisions
financières intéressant l'aménagement
des halles pourrait être prise
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle qu
avant-hier mardi à l'elysée à l'occasion
d'une réunion de travail consacrée à
l'aménagement du quartier des halles
monsieur giscard d'estaing président de
la république avec un être son intention
de remplacer le centre international de
commerce prévue sur l'emplacement des
anciennes halles de paris par un espace
vert rarement un quartier de la capitale
aura suscité autant de polémiques
à quand remonte le début des discussions
quelles sont les conséquences de la
décision du président de la république
voici pour que vous puissiez juger le
lot si les halles
c'est une histoire à rebondissements à
l'origine une décision imposée pour des
raisons essentiellement techniques le
transfert des halles du centre de la
capitale
a rungis paris qui n'a plus de ventre va
retrouver un coeur car au delà de la
polémique de caractère esthétique et
fonctionnel qui entoure la décision de
détruire les pavillons baltard la fête
envahi ces lieux désertés il manquait à
paris un lieu de rencontre des changes
les parisiens semblaient l'avoir trouvé
mais voilà cet emplacement devait
susciter un grand nombre de projets plus
ou moins désintéressés
le conseil de paris tranche et donne son
feu vert à une vaste opération de
rénovation de zone principale à l'est
sur le plateau beaubourg création d'un
centre d'art contemporain
déjà surnommé george pompidou il s'agit
de mettre sur cet espace 2 hectares une
grande bibliothèque publique
d'information à département des arts
plastiques et groupera le musée national
d'art moderne de san national d'art
contemporain à une documentation
spécialisée il s'agit également de
mettre le centre de création
industrielle et de faire intervenir la
recherche musicale et acoustique dans un
institut de recherche et coordination
acoustique musique qui se trouve
enterrée à côté du centre beaubourg au
chevet de l'église san et un bâtiment
qui fait qu'ils couvrent 10 mille mètres
carrés au sol qui a cinq étages et qui
se trouve au milieu d'un environnement
de deux hectares où l'on trouve des
endroits piétonnier des lieux de
promenade et de détente que ce soit la
place qui se trouve devant le centre
cela place qui se trouve au chevet de
l'église st mary où la place d'areni qui
se trouve un peu en dehors du périmètre
vaut un peu plus à l'ouest
un grand forum souterrain hauteur et aux
alentours du rer en construction enfin à
l'emplacement des anciennes halles à
proximité de la bourse du commerce de
l'église saint-eustache un centre de
commerce international 94 mille mètres
carrés dont quatorze mille en surface un
centre d'affaires et d'information pour
4 à 500 sociétés françaises et
étrangères qui pourraient disposer de
locaux
mais ce centre de commerce international
on le sait depuis mardi ne verra pas le
jour
le président de la république a été
catégorique le projet doit être
abandonnée au profit d' espaces verts il
faut le dire ce centre avait suscité
bien des critiques de la part
d'associations pour la protection du
site et récemment encore son permis de
construire avait été annulé par le
tribunal administratif de pas
apparemment personnes s'attendaient à
cette décision
j'en suis d'autant plus déçu que vous
mmes interviewé à peu de choses près à
l'endroit où président de la république
ministre des finances il ya un an au
mois de juillet déclaré sur cet
emplacement qu'il était venu
salué l'assemblée des centres
internationaux dans le monde 40 nations
dont les ruches des américains et c'est
un écueil se réjouit serge lejeune
textes l'un on se réjouissait d'être ici
et du choix du bâtiment dans les
proportions étaient compatibles avec le
quartier et qu'il souhaitait que paris
capitale d'un pays qui est 4e
commerçants du monde et possède un
centre de commerce international alors
c'est là vraiment très grande surprise à
sa grande surprise alors en fin de
compte que va devenir cet emplacement
l'emmenant à ça je n'en sais rien c'est
que lorsque je sais ça ce je suppose que
vous interview vrai monsieur aaron le
promoteur lui il a un problème alors
strictement financier c'est à dire des
sommes investies pour en arriver à la
situation nous trouvons c'est-à-dire un
trou de 20 mètres de profondeur sur un
hectare et demi ce qui représente des
centaines de milliers de mètres cubes de
terre des ingénieurs des architectes des
travaux des terrassements beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent à mon sens le
fait de voir huit ans de travail acharné
d'une équipe qui croyons quelque chose
stoppez d'une seconde à l'autre ne peut
conduire qu'à sur deux sentiments alors
est ce que cela signifie que le principe
d'un grand centre d'affaires de ce genre
à paris est également intérêt pour le
moment aucune information précise à ce
sujet
pourtant on reconnaît qu'un centre
commercial international à paris serait
une chose importante
alors est ce que malgré tout le principe
risque d'être abandonnée définitivement
donc à présent il est ici en tout cas
savoir s'il sera proposé ailleurs et de
nos problèmes
pour nous il n'est pas le moment d'y
penser la seul axe d'action qui peut
être le nôtre d'abord et de sauvegarder
le terrain tels qu'ils existent faire en
sorte que les bâtiments avoisinants ne
ris pas le comme on dit vulgairement de
tomber dans le trou et puis ensuite nous
verrons
mais pour le moment je crois que nos
préoccupations ne sont pas celles d'une
nouvelle conception puisque
éventuellement si on vous appelle à vous
pour réaliser ce ce centre commercial
international peut-être dans un autre
endroit paris ou à la périphérie est ce
que vous répondrez riez présent il est
évident que notre goût a été d'étudier
ce genre de bâtiment que nous recevons
comme étant très utile à l'économie d'un
pays puisqu'ils ont construit des
quantités dans le monde maintenant il
est non moins évident que compte de
cette expérience nous serions des
heureux de penser un nouveau bâtiment
faut-il encore savoir où il peut se
trouver
et puis surtout quelle sécurité nous
sera offerte cette fois ci pour que l'
ouvrage sont menés à bien
jusqu'au bout à l'hôtel de ville on
affiche une certaine déception
le conseil municipal n'a pas été
consulté pour cette nouvelle option
j'avoue avoir un petit regret c'est que
le conseil de paris et ses élus n'est
pas du tout était en conversation au
sujet de cette modification sur venu
pour l'aménagement des halles mais il
s'agit maintenant de savoir comment nous
pouvons le mieux faire cette opération
venant après les décisions concernant la
voie express rive gauche la cité fleurie
cette affaire d'aménagement pose deux
questions quel doit être le partage des
compétences entre le chef de l'état et
le conseil de paris et enfin s'agit-il
d'une action isolée ou d'une véritable
redéfinition de l'urbanisme parisien